foreign
when I was a kid the violin was the
center of my life
I'd run home from the bus stop after
school and practice for hours
every Saturday my mom and I would wake
up at four in the morning to catch a
train to New York so I could study at
Juilliard
here's a throwback to eight-year-old me
performing the violin
some questionable fashion choices from
Young Maya here not gonna lie
but anyway when I was a teenager my
musical Idol Itzhak Perlman invited me
to be his private student and my big
dream of becoming a concert violinist
felt Within Reach
but then one morning when I was 15 I was
practicing this tricky technical Passage
I struggled to get it right and I
overextended my finger on a single note
I heard a popping sound
I permanently damaged the tendons in my
hand and my dream was over
I share this story because unexpected
change happens to all of us
an accident or an illness a relationship
that suddenly ends
today I'm not a violinist but I'm a
cognitive scientist and I'm interested
in how we respond to exactly this kind
of change
I spent the past few decades studying
the science of human behavior and today
I host a podcast called a slight change
of plans
[Music]
glad you guys like it where I interview
people from all over the world about
their life-altering experiences
I started this podcast because change is
scary for a lot of us am I right
for one it is filled with uncertainty
and we hate uncertainty
research shows that we're more stressed
when we're told we have a 50 chance of
getting an electric shock then when
we're told we have a 100 chance
that's wild right I mean we'd rather be
sure that a bad thing is going to happen
than to have to deal with any
uncertainty
change is also scary because it involves
loss of some kind
by definition we're departing from an
old way of being and entering a new one
and when we experience a change that we
wouldn't have chosen for ourselves it's
easy to feel that our lives are
Contracting that we're more limited than
before
but when we take this perspective we
fail to account for an important fact
that when an unexpected change happens
to us it can also Inspire lasting change
within us
we become different people on the other
side of change what we're capable of
what we value and how we Define
ourselves
these things can all shift
and if we can learn to pay close
attention to these internal shifts we
may just find that rather than limiting
us
change can actually expand us
all right today I'm going to share with
you three questions you can ask yourself
the next time life throws you that
dreaded curveball
in the moment I know it's so easy to
focus on what you've lost and so I'm
really hoping that you can use these
questions as tools to discover all that
you might gain
all right let's start with question
number one
this is inspired by a conversation I had
on my podcast with a woman named
Christine ha and it's about our
capabilities
Christine was 24 when a rare autoimmune
disease left her permanently blind
at the time she was learning to cook the
Vietnamese dishes that she had loved in
childhood
but now cooking even simple meals was
tough
she told me that her frustration peaked
one day when she was making a peanut
butter and jelly sandwich
she struggled to align the two slices of
bread and sticky jelly dripped all over
her hands and onto the counter
she threw the sandwich into the trash
and she felt really defeated by the
Limited future that she imagined for
herself
since Christine lived alone though she
had no choice but to keep at it
she remembers her Delight when she
successfully cut an orange for the first
time and when she scrambled an egg
without burning it
as she spent more hours in the kitchen
she realized that cooking was far more
multi-sensory than she had thought
while she couldn't see if the garlic had
browned she could rely on the smell and
the sizzling sounds in the pan
but Christine also realized something
bigger
something new was emerging within her
at the start of her vision loss she had
cooked just to get by I mean it was
really just a practical thing
but now she was thrilled by the
challenge of it all
she tackled harder and harder recipes
over the years
and eventually became the first ever
blind contestant on the TV show
MasterChef
and guess what she won the entire damn
thing
Christine's a rock star but she's an
amazing amazing person
this brings us to the first question
that you can ask yourself the next time
you face something unexpected
how might this change change what you're
capable of
when we predict how we'll respond to any
given change
we tend to imagine what our present day
selves will be like in that new
situation
research by the psychologist Dan Gilbert
shows that we greatly underestimate how
much will change in the future even
though we fully acknowledge we've
changed considerably in the past
our psychology continually tricks us
into believing that who we are right now
in this very moment is the person that's
here to stay
but the person meeting the challenges
after an unexpected change will be
different you will be different
today Christine is a world-renowned chef
she goes by the nickname The Blind cook
and she owns three restaurants in Texas
and importantly
she's really curious about what else she
can achieve without vision
these days you can find her snowboarding
and rock climbing on the weekends
Christine shared with me something that
she could have never have imagined
thinking before all this
that I've given the choice today
she would choose not to have her vision
restored
though she did tell me she'd like it
back for a moment because she really
wants to know what Justin Bieber looks
like
all right let's move on to the second
question
this one is about our values and it's
inspired by a conversation I had with a
science journalist named Florence
Williams
one evening about five years ago
Florence and her husband were hosting a
dinner party for their friends
as she was preparing the salad her
husband handed her his phone so that she
could read an email from a relative
but he'd mistakenly pulled up the wrong
email
what Florence son said was a lengthy
note from her husband confessing his
love to another woman
I know
Florence's 25-year marriage came to an
end and she told me that she was taken
aback by the physical and emotional
intensity of her heartbreak
she said it felt like she'd been plugged
into a faulty electrical socket
since Florence is a problem solver by
Nature she instinctively saw her
heartbreak as a problem to solve and
develop a year-long systematic plan to
try and fix it
Florence tried a bunch of things
she took solo trips into the Wilderness
she tried a range of experimental
therapies she even went to the Museum of
broken relationships which I promise is
a thing
you name it she tried it
but by the end of the year none of these
remedies had healed her broken heart
and so Florence had no choice but to
entertain a new philosophy altogether
Navy a broken heart was not a problem to
solve
and maybe closure wasn't the answer
research by the psychologist Dr Keltner
shows that when we reduce our need for
what's called cognitive closure the
desire to arrive at clear and definitive
answers
our capacity to feel Joy and Beauty
expands
Florence told me that when she freed
herself from this goal-oriented mindset
a mindset by the way that she had valued
for so much of her life up until this
point
she began to find unexpected Delight in
the unknown
just to the second question you can ask
yourself the next time you face
something unexpected
how might this change
what you value
the unexpected implosion of Florence's
marriage has permanently shifted the way
that she sees her life
from a puzzle in need of solutions to a
more serendipitous path of discovery
now when Florence goes hiking she's just
as likely to sit still feeling the
breeze as she is to try and make the
summit
she no longer makes five-year plans
and she's comfortable not knowing all
the answers around her heartbreak
by the way I was texting with Florence
the other day and she's currently in a
very happy relationship
my ex-husband is listening to this I
just want him to know she's doing great
buddy
all right now on to question number
three this one is about how we Define
ourselves it's about our self identities
and it comes from my personal story of
change with the violin
when my injury took the violin away from
me I found myself grieving not just the
loss of the instrument but also the loss
of myself
for so long the violin had defined me
that without it I wasn't sure who I was
or who I could be
I felt stuck
I'd later learned that this phenomenon
is known as identity paralysis it
happens to a lot of us when we Face the
unexpected
who we think we are and what we're about
is suddenly called into question
but I since realized that there was
something different
something more stable that I could have
anchored my identity to
and this brings us to that third and
final question
how might this change
how you define yourself
when I re-examined my relationship with
the violin I discovered that what I
really missed wasn't the instrument
itself
but the fact that music had given me a
vehicle for connecting emotionally with
others
I remember as a little kid playing for
people and feeling kind of awestruck
that we might all feel something new
together
what this means for me today is that I
no longer anchor my identity to specific
Pursuits like being a violinist or a
cognitive scientist or a podcaster
instead I anchor my identity to what
lights me up about those Pursuits what
really energizes me
and for me it's a love of human
connection and understanding
I now Define myself not by what I do
but why I do it
look unexpected change comes for us all
whether we like it or not and when it
does it can really suck
but I'm hoping that if we can stay open
to how we might internally change how we
might expand it can help us weather the
storm
life recently through me a new slight
change of plans
I've always wanted to be a mom but
becoming one has been difficult and my
husband and I have had to navigate
pregnancy losses and other heartbreaks
over the years
and now I'm not sure what will happen
but I'm using these three questions to
help me during this tough time
I'm asking myself how this unexpected
challenge might change what I'm capable
of
what I value
and how I Define myself
I'm still figuring things out
um but what I can tell you right now is
that
I'm imagining a future me who is
expanding her definition of what it
means to parent
who's perhaps finding what she craved
from motherhood in other places
at a minimum this exploration has
allowed me to loosen my grip on the
identity of mom just a bit
and I found it freeing
I'm beginning to see change with more
possibility and I'm hoping you can too
thank you so much
foreign